Literally, that is closer to defamation
than anything Noah has ever said about
Ethan. What are we noticing here?
Are we seeing what's actually happening
here? This is in his lawsuit. It's his
own still.
>> Works good in one of these silly little
hit videos. Let's try it on a judge.
>> There's zero credible evidence. What
does Ethan cite? Hassan said it.
Mind-blowing. Why are we here today?
Ethan Klein has announced he's suing
Noah Samson. It is a defamation suit
this time. So, you know, off the bat,
it's like I don't have this super
principled issue to just the filing. And
then I mean the act of filing alone.
Because his issue is he claims to feel
like Noah has defamed him. And so he is
filing a defamation lawsuit, which is
obviously a massive improvement upon
Ethan's last round of lawsuits, where he
had deeply personal issues with these
people and claimed to feel like he'd
been defamed and instead chose to launch
copyright lawsuits, where they long
months-long trap him in lane to to
specifically target those people. So,
this time, slightly different. Actually
doing a defamation lawsuit for his
defamation issue. So, I think we're just
going to get straight into the stream.
What's Ethan saying about the lawsuit?
What's it over? Ethan versus Noah
Samson. Absolutely huge content
happening here.
>> Hello.
Ethan Klein here coming at you live from
Los Angeles, California.
>> Let's go. Come on.
>> Come on. Wednesday, April
2026. You know it's almost Hitler's
birthday in 12 days here coming up
again.
It's your pal
>> Aha.
>> Four days it's Hitler's birthday.
Okay. Which also happens to be the same
day that we celebrate blazing, 420. How
about that?
>> It's also the anniversary of the
Columbine shooting. You didn't mention
that one, Ethan. You didn't mention.
>> Now you're talking.
>> How about that, huh? What does it mean?
What does it mean? We don't know. Google
it.
Today we're sponsored by Cozy Earth.
Thank you so much to them.
Love that.
Um today we are discussing
old friend of the show, Noah Samson,
that's right. Uh Uh
Spoke about It's been a while since I
spoke about dear friend Noah Samson, who
had a penchant for accusing me of being
pro genocide.
He thought it was cute. He thought it
was uh
fun throwing around such kind of heinous
accusations, right? This guy supports
genocide. In fact, he had a video called
The YouTubers That Supported a Genocide
With Me in It.
And um you know, that's the world of it.
>> coughing, retching, decaying on every
episode of the show.
>> and
excuse me. In fact, let me just Google
this name you can see.
Here I
I made a promise to him
March of last year.
>> reflects the soul.
>> And um I think I think he probably
thought that it had blown over. I think
a lot of people probably thought it blew
over. In fact,
the statute of limitation is passed.
But,
I of course kept a close eye on that.
You see, the statute of limitation uh
for certain
certain uh statute of complaints like
defamation and such. If you don't sue
within I think it's a year of a
defamatory claim,
it blows away like dust in the wind.
But,
to what to those of us who are shrewd,
we keep we keep a tab on those things.
And I'll tell you what I am assuming is
that Noah himself
thought himself to be shrewd.
I even alluded to it on the show. I
said,
"Well, it seems to me that Noah is
ducking
out, playing hooky on society.
Seems to be on the lam. He's got no name
on utilities or anywhere.
That for example, if you were to to hire
a private investigator
to get the information on somebody to
serve them, he he couldn't be found.
>> Which I'm assuming Isn't that kind of
[__] awesome? That kind of makes Noah
sound [__] awesome.
>> And at that age in your life has to be a
you know, a
conscious attempt.
And so we we waited,
you know.
And on the day of or the day before the
statute uh expired,
we had a nice little complaint there for
defamation
for accusing me of being pro-genocide,
in favor of genocide. Horrible thing to
say about someone, by the way.
One of the worst, I would say, maybe
even.
Of all the things you could say about
someone.
You know.
>> Well, rather because Destiny said you
molested your kids and you're not suing
him.
So, I I can think of worse things to say
about someone that you're not taking
action against. Like the like the un-
unless you think that being
the idea of being pro-genocide is more
offensive and untrue to you than the
idea that you molested your kids, but
I would uh I'm taking the charitable
interpretation here, I guess.
Which is that you're lying.
>> Beating the statute by about 1 day.
Now, most of the time people see these
immediately, but we were under the
radar. We filed it in um
Orange County, I believe.
Which um is not trolled by media and
press, so it went under the radar.
Nobody even saw until now, in fact.
Nobody knew
that uh we I was even suing Noah Samson.
Well, he knew since a couple of days
ago, since he was served. But, he's the
only one.
Let me take a sip.
It's pretty refreshing.
>> Which flavor is that?
>> The only one that matters, Tom.
>> Damn right.
>> Strawberry lemonade.
>> Shut up.
>> With caffeine.
>> Shut up, Tom.
>> All right, chill. Relax.
You wait your turn.
Idubz, get in line.
>> Yeah, but
>> Turned out Noah
thinking he was clever.
>> There's that lawsuit threat at Idubz as
well.
>> because he would lose due to discovery.
>> Is he guys If he sues Idubz, that would
be hilarious. That would actually be
hilarious. I would love I would love the
Idubz
forced redemption arc
through uh Ethan Klein suing him for
some stupid [__] Um you didn't say
CPS in your video.
>> Came off the grid.
It was time to come out of hiding, so I
thought he was doing. Because it turns
out right after
we filed this uh lawsuit of ours
that we did another very standard
boilerplate search like private
investigators do every day to find
the the of such complaints, to serve
them.
As you have to serve them as a very
integral part of
suing somebody.
And I've been involved in a lot of
lawsuits and I've never had these types
of trouble locating someone for service.
But, you know, just like when the rain
falls and the worms and snails come
slithering out of their shelters for one
drop of rain,
so too came slithering Noah Samson.
Turns out
it wasn't rain, it was the sprinklers.
Because we caught him
and we served him. And Noah Samson, who
was served about 2 days ago, has been
pretty mum's the word on it,
surprisingly.
>> No, guys, you don't understand. This guy
Ethan's really cool and funny and epic.
He's like fun more funny and epic things
ever been.
You don't understand. He makes like fat
jokes about women sometimes or talks
about,
you know, sexual details of other
people's
relationships in a really bizarre,
obsessed, or you know,
almost
what would you call it?
Is it Is it Yeah, voyeuristic way.
Voyeuristic way.
It's really awesome. It's really
awesome. You don't understand. It's not
just some neurotic middle-aged man
suffering from
obvious mental health and physical
health issues freaking the [__] out at
literally anyone that responds to him
online and filing lawsuits in a constant
tantrum.
He's really epic, actually. He's really
epic.
>> He's been sued now
in California for defamation.
That's right. He thought I forgot. In
fact,
nobody should be surprised. This is me
following through on a promise I made a
a year ago.
And by the way,
many people, friends and comrades of
his,
have said that I'm only suing women.
And it's been, you know,
me of course
>> Yeah, Ethan's having a bad reaction to a
tryna crime, guys. Give him a break.
>> have a majority female audience who I
respect
more than anyone in the world. I love,
respect women.
And so,
to dispel this terrible accusation that
I only sue men or women, I'm sorry. I
thought it only fair and equitable
to sue a man.
A white man, I might say. Um
>> Very brave.
>> Well, it's it's equitable and and I want
and it's important for me to know
to the three women
that um
it's not personal, right? I I sue those
who
who deserve it. Who who who require
accountability. And it was a terrible
coincidence, terrible one,
that the three people I sued for
copyright infringement were women.
Terrible, right?
And I'm just happy that I've had the
opportunity to rectify that, to set the
record straight now, to sue a straight
white man.
>> Wow, hahaha.
Okay.
We don't give a [__] about his like
whinging about people saying he's sexist
and all this stupid [__]
>> AKA the defamatory video.
>> Let's get to the main point now. He's
not showing the lawsuit here.
So, as you can see, he's saying the
defamatory video is this Noah Samson
video called The YouTubers Who Backed a
Genocide.
Now, we just watched quite a bit of that
video.
And I cannot possibly [__] imagine
what the defamatory claims in that video
are.
It genuinely boggles the mind. This is
absurd
to me. This is like totally absurd to
me. I can't I literally cannot picture
what you would sue Noah over in that
video.
>> The thumbnail for the defamatory video
depicts various individuals, including
the plaintiff Ethan Klein.
Samson knew that Ethan
ferociously advocated against the
genocide of Palestinians. Despite this,
Samson and his business, Samson
Creative,
published the defamatory video to
falsely paint Ethan as supporting the
genocide of Palestinians. The
defendant's defamatory video was
incredibly successful. To date,
it has received approximately 1.5
million views and is defendant's most
second most viewed video on YouTube, you
know.
That's the other thing about this.
Noah Samson,
when he's not accusing people of
supporting genocide,
for example, this video about the
war in Gaza, the IDF's plan to return to
Gaza with no constraints one month ago.
It only got 32,000 views.
So,
the man has quite a vested interest here
in
defaming people.
It's good for business, it seems.
In fact, he said as much, which we quote
here in this beautiful beautiful
complaint. Gorgeous.
>> This 14-page meticulously argued
document. True.
>> It's true what he says, except it's 32.
Can we maybe get
>> 32.
Damn you, good.
>> Meticulous 32-page document. We need
Dark Viper to say it though, yeah?
Uh excuse me here.
>> No, [__] you.
>> Yeah, exactly. Well, that's So, that's
in here, but he's quoted as even saying
uh [__] on me is algorithmically
viable. The Ethan Klein crash out
industrial complex is booming, he said.
And he, of course, was the original and
chief one of beneficiaries of that
industry.
>> Crit See, yeah, basically here it's
laying out
oh, you can't say Ethan and Hila are
pro-genocide because they said they were
they really didn't like some stuff
Israel does in the past.
They said it was really bad. They don't
like stuff Israel does in the past. So,
you can't say they support genocide.
Obviously, it's [__] to claim that
someone cannot be pro-genocide because
they've claimed that they're against the
genocide in the past.
Because you can draw conclusions about
someone's actual positions that
contradict a statement they've made. So,
if Noa Samson takes a bunch of evidence
that suggests Ethan Klein actually does
support the genocide, simply the fact
that he has said at one point, I don't,
does not discredit that. It does not
necessarily discredit that. And it's
very hard to prove that statement is
essentially opinion. It's a read of
Ethan. It's a It's a read of Ethan's
uh both true feelings and the role he
plays with his content, sort of like the
the way his content presents
um
Israel, right?
Through the content, Yuke. Cuz the whole
video Noa made
is like a It's framed around Ethan,
but most of it is just about
Israel-Palestine.
And it's basically the idea is I'm
filling you in with a bunch of
information that's negative about Israel
that you won't have seen if the only
engagement you have with this conflict
is through
the content nuke.
That's basically what it's doing is it's
saying
Ethan Klein viewers only see
uh Israel through Ethan Klein. Here's
another side Here's the other side to
it. And then he talks about the way
their coverage uh in both Ethan Ethan's
coverage, Mutahar, Turkey Tom of uh the
Azm al-Ghoul situation and stuff
adjacent to that has played into
supporting a genocide. And that is all
opinion. That is all opinion.
You can say
oh, I I think that your
content supports genocide in the way it
presents Israel-Palestine. That's
totally fine. You can make that
assessment. It's very hard for that to
be for that to be defamatory.
It's very hard for it to be defamatory.
It's like crazy to try and sue over
something like that.
>> Critics of the Israeli government, Prime
Minister Benyamin Net
Ben Netanyahu
>> [__] ass Netanyahu.
>> Prime Minister Benjamin Bibi Netanyahu
>> Really went in on the Jew [__] there.
>> Both before and after October 7th, Ethan
and Ela condemned Israel's oppression
and violence toward the Palestinian
people, including explicitly stating
Israel's actions constitute a genocide.
That would be in direct conflict with
Noah's defamatory claim. Not good for
him.
Ethan and Ela advocate for a two-state
solution to resolve the conflict. Both
Ethan and Ela are Israelis. Ethan by
naturalization and Ela by birth. Nearly
all of Ela's family reside in Israel.
Ela and her family are also Mizrahi
Jews.
I.e. Jews from Arab and Muslim countries
who came to Israel as refugees escaping
violence and oppression.
Both Ethan Both Ethan and Ela know that
if Jews were expelled from Israel, the
vast majority would have nowhere to go.
This is the primary reason why they
advocate for a two-state solution
instead of one state.
Samson makes his position on the
Israel-Palestine conflict, unequivocally
clear. Israel must be wiped off the face
of the earth. He advocates that anyone
who supports the existence of Israel is
a valid target.
He's an adamant believer of there are no
bad means, only bad targets.
As such,
he engages in very the very behavior
rhetoric he reportedly condemns to paint
his targets
as evil.
Wow.
Sounds like a bad guy, this Noah Samson.
Samson knows that Ethan has condemned
Israel's actions as a genocide.
He simply doesn't care about the fact.
Samson brands Ethan as a genocide
supporter because he does not advocate
for the complete destruction of Israel
and Israelis.
>> It's not true.
>> Again, this is a really important
>> That's just not true. That is just not
true. That's not the argument the video
makes whatsoever.
That is literally that is closer to
defamation
than anything Noah has ever said about
Ethan.
Saying he Noah Samson claims the reason
he claims that they are pro-genocide cuz
they don't think Israel should be wiped
off the face of the map. No, he actually
made a massive argument in that video
had nothing to do with that that showed
how Ethan selectively
um
cherry-picked like bits of history to
show in the content nuke and uh what
what he do? He like he does that big
[__] up with the the like Nakba uh death
and displacement count. Where it's like
he basically
um
like what is it? He does like this
[__] equivalent I can't remember
exactly what the phrasing is. I'd have
to go back and watch the video again.
But he does like that [__]
equivalent with like
Jews uh pushed out over a massive
stretch of time versus just the Nakba.
Um
and like gets the count wrong for the
Nakba as well.
And it's just like
there there is an easy argument you can
make about any piece of content like
that that it is pro-genocide because all
it takes is you believe there is a
genocide happening, this piece of
content functionally supports Israel or
whitewashes the actions are taking,
therefore that supports genocide.
And that is an opinion you can have.
That is an opinion that is and should be
first amendment protected. There is no
doubt in my mind. Literally no doubt in
my mind that that's the case.
It's [__] absurd. It's so [__]
absurd.
>> Important point to clarify and to
memorialize here in this legal filing
because
at the end of the day, I think the the
majority of people pushing this Ethan's
a genocide supporter narrative
is because
I don't
completely
um
advocate for Israel's total destruction.
And that's that's that's what it takes
basically to be to be branded an enemy.
The defendant's defamatory video seeks
to prove as a factual matter
that Ethan advocates for the genocide of
Palestinians. And it achieves its
objective by one, misrepresenting source
materials, two, relying on clearly
biased sources, some of which have also
spread falsehoods about Ethan, and three
through other defamatory statements
about Ethan.
This lawsuit seeks to prove that ad-
advocacy for the Palestinian cause does
not require falsely branding advocates
of a two-state solution as sanctioning
genocide. To the contrary, doing so
impedes the Palestinian cause because it
engages in the very behavior that these
so-called advocates
>> Well, that sounds super relevant to a
defamation claim, Ethan.
All this grandstanding sounds super
relevant to a defamation claim. I can
see this is written about as poorly as
the last one.
>> to condemn.
This is exactly what Samson did and why
the defendants must be held accountable
for falsely asserting that Ethan
advocates the genocide of Palestinians
despite knowing that his statement is
false.
That's tough.
This is just some factual recollections.
Plaintiff Ethan Klein lives in
California. Defended Samson, uh
has a California business.
Yada yada. Defendant Noah Samson has
principal business Samson Creative,
located in Orange County. Yada yada,
Bob's your uncle.
Now they talk about jurisdiction. This
is all very
What's the word? Procedural. Proce-
Procedural. Let's see. So, um
This is just saying the court has
jurisdiction.
He's in Orange County. Yada yada. So,
here's factual allegations.
Background on Ethan Klein. Ethan, along
with his wife, are among the most
recognized YouTuber content creators.
>> We are here for the reading, dude.
>> They have various YouTube channels.
As you guys know, yada yada. And we also
own a streetwear company, Teddy Fresh,
as you guys know. We met in Israel 20
years ago. Yada yada, Bob's your uncle.
We got married.
Moved to the USA. We've been outspoken
supporters for the Palestinian cause of
self-determination and statehood.
And we're also
fierce critics of the state of Israel,
even before October 7th. Noteworthy
examples include
on October Sorry, November 11th, 2017,
I conducted an interview with Hila.
During an interview,
we engaged in a nuanced conversation
about the Israel-Palestine conflict and
expressed strong criticism of the
Israeli government and the IDF. Isr-
Hila also discussed how much she
detested serving in the IDF, where she
served.
>> Uh-huh. Is that what happened? Is that
what happened? Shall we just
Hila spoke about how much she hated
>> You served in the military.
Did And your whole family served in the
military, right?
>> Mhm.
>> What did How was your experience in the
military?
>> Um
it was okay.
>> Oh.
>> Uh I I didn't do anything like I wasn't
like a combative
role.
>> Yeah, you weren't a fighter.
>> I wasn't a fighter.
So,
I didn't have anything like crazy.
>> She She hated serving. It was okay.
It was okay.
>> Some computer thing.
>> Right, okay. So, it's a secretary.
>> Yeah.
>> Interesting.
>> And it was super boring and I really
hate
>> No, not just a secretary, Ethan. She was
doing logistics. She was doing
logistics, Ethan. She was
helping plan
military action.
>> Did it.
Cuz it was just like I had to take an
exam
>> Just cuz Just cuz it was a you know, a
seemingly
small part of that where it's oh, she's
sorting out hotels. That does not mean
she was not doing logistics for the IDF.
That like
the whitewashing even here is insane.
>> I super early, go there, spend the whole
day, go back home.
I hated it.
So, I tried to change my mind.
>> I did the long ass train rides.
>> And um it was something like you can
apply for it and it's a form that you
fill out and then they're going to give
you something else completely random.
You have no idea.
>> Mhm.
>> Different post.
>> Yeah.
>> Different location.
>> So, I decided to do that and if I don't
like the second one, then I'll just find
a way to get out of the army.
>> It was that bad?
>> Yeah. I just didn't I hated everything
about it. Didn't want to do it.
>> Okay, hated everything about it, didn't
want to do it.
>> You just cuz if you're doing something
that
>> But she didn't
>> like I wasn't doing anything. Like I was
just wasting my life.
>> She went to a new post.
>> It could get really frustrating. I don't
know.
>> Right. And why did she detest it? Cuz it
felt like she was wasting her life. She
wasn't really doing much.
>> something that it felt like I wasn't
doing anything. Like I was just wasting
my life.
>> Yeah.
>> It could get really frustrating. I don't
know.
>> Right.
>> And you got to do it for 2 years.
>> Right. Oh my god, two two whole years.
Oh my god.
>> filled out a form and and then
I somehow
ended up in a better place that I liked
>> Oh, but you did Oh, oh, but you you did
find a new place when you actually enjoy
Oh, okay.
>> Um
>> You're not supposed to
>> this video is meant to disprove the idea
that they that they support Israel in
the genocide, okay?
That's what this video is meant to help
disprove the idea
that Ela has any positive feelings
towards Israel whatsoever.
>> No, yeah, not really. But even if I
would
I mean, I I walked with them to one
house.
>> Okay.
>> get out of the car once.
But but surrounded with them, so
>> Okay.
Did they arrest anyone that night?
>> They didn't.
>> Did they bring it in the same car with
you?
>> No.
>> Oh, different car.
>> There was a few cars going.
>> Damn, that's crazy.
Was it Like, how did you feel? Was it
horrifying?
>> It was strange.
>> Very
very weird.
>> How so? Like, how so?
>> Um
Uh, I don't know. Just
you see people in their house, and then
it's like
the soldiers go just walk into the house
and
look through their [__] and find guns
the whole thing is really surreal.
>> Right.
>> So, great stuff there.
>> served as a secretary.
On October On December 8th, 2020, Ethan
conducted a conversation with co-host at
the time, Trisha Paytas. Shout out
to the great Zionist Trisha Paytas
about the Israel-Palestine conflict. He
explained to Paytas why she should not
be dismissive of the quote free
Palestine movement and understand that
the Palestinian perspective of the
conflict, even referring back then,
referring to Israel's actions against
Palestinian people as a genocide and as
apartheid.
That's not good for you, Noah. On May
15th, 2021,
Ethan made an Instagram post condemning
Israel and and Netanyahu, which was
liked by Ela because she agreed with it.
Let the record show.
This occurred during the Unity Intifada
that took place May 10th, 2021 through
May
21. The post was made specifically in
response to the IDF destroying the Al
Jazeera building, which housed Al
Jazeera and the Associated Press.
>> Wow.
>> On October 9th, 2023, 2 days after
October 7th, Ethan, Hila, and the crew
of the H3 podcast discussed how innocent
Palestinians would suffer from Israel's
reaction to October 7th because the
Israeli government is barbaric,
genocidal freaks. That's 2 days after.
And
genocidal war criminals amongst other
criticism.
On October 12th, a mere 3 days later,
Ethan conducted a near 4-hour
conversation about the conflict
where he described Israel's actions
against the Palestinians once again as a
genocide. Openly wept, calling the
images of a Palestinian father holding
his dead infant
>> Like, literally, none of this proves
that it's even false, let alone
defamatory. Because the argument
is not that Ethan has never said
anything condemning of Israel.
The argument is
that Ethan Klein, in his content, you
has supported a genocide.
That's the argument. Is that Ethan
Klein's content supports a genocide.
That's not his opinion.
And it's it should be, and I believe to
be, first amendment protected. You can
absolutely make that argument. It's very
easy argument to make, in fact. Some
would say very hard argument to contest.
>> Fink.
He called Benjamin Netanyahu a war
criminal amongst any other many other
statements showing
support and empathy for the Palestinian
people.
So, right here in blue and black.
>> It's all blue.
>> And black. On November 20th, Ethan and
the crew of the H3 podcast discussed
their hope for seeing a ceasefire and an
end to the atrocities in Gaza. On March
2nd of 2024, Ethan reiterates that he
considers Israel's treatment of the
Palestinians to be an apartheid and a
genocide. On November 25th of 2024,
Ethan had an hour and a half
conversation with the Arab online
creator, LonerBox, about the history of
the Israeli-Arab conflict. On May 23rd,
>> Arab only, creator, dude.
>> All right.
2025, Ethan had an hour-long
conversation with Palestinian activist
and scholar Ahmed Fouad
about pragmatic solutions to the
conflict. Ethan Yousef also made
numerous donations to
Palestinian-focused charities. On
October 16th, 2023,
a mere week
after the tragic events,
Ethan Yousef donated $6,500 to a
fundraiser for the charitable
organizations called
ANERA, Palestinian Children's Relief
Fund, Palestinian Red Crescent Society,
and Medical Aid for Palestinians.
On May 17th, Ethan Yousef donated $1,250
to a fundraiser for the charitable
organization called Palestinian uh
Children Relief Fund.
On May 23rd, 2025, Ethan Yousef donated
$1,000 to the World Food Programme's
Gaza Fund, and another thousand to
Re-Align for Palestine. On September
28th, 2025, Ethan
and Ethan donated $1,000 to a
fundraiser, once again, for the
Palestinian Children Relief Fund.
Critically, on on January 31st, Ethan
Yousef, through the production company,
released a feature-length documentary
called Content Cop,
or sorry, Content Nuke, as Hasan [__]
The Nuke documented how the prominent
political streamer, Hasan [__]
repeatedly supported terrorist
organizations, namely the Houthis,
Hezbollah, and Hamas. And during this
video, Ethan repeated and emphasized his
condemnation of Israel's treatment of
Palestine.
Sounds pretty robust.
And this is the problem for Dear Noah.
He can speak in inferences and
suggestions and innuendo, but at the end
of the day, my friend, in court, we got
to talk about the facts on the paper.
And you're going to have a really hard
time, as you did in your video essays,
honestly proving that I'm anything you
said I did. I look forward to you
attempting
>> Dude, I literally I cannot wait to get
to what the claims he's actually saying
at the defamation trial. I cannot wait
to see it in claim.
>> Uh before I move on to the next part
here, Noah Samson.
>> Come on, get in. Let's go, Paul.
>> Back to my boy,
Noah Samson.
Um,
could you peel that for me?
>> Mhm.
>> Thank you so much. Fantastic. Isn't she
great, folks?
Uh, Samson published videos on YouTube
through his entity.
Prior to October 7th, Samson never made
a video about Israel-Palestine.
Is that [__] interesting or what?
Prior to October 7th, Noah Samson never
made a video about Israel-Palestine
conflict.
You know who had talked about it several
times? Me.
What a rat.
Rather, he made videos talking about
online drama, along with attacking
conservatives and anti-woke content.
After October 7th, Samson suddenly
became a self-styled expert in the
Israel-Palestine conflict.
Throughout his online career, Samson has
a notorious reputation for sloppy
research, misrepresenting his sources,
and making false statements.
Okay, sounds like a great guy.
It's almost like he was jumping on a
fad.
It's almost like the industrial complex
was booming, as he said.
Despite claiming to support women and
people of color, including Palestinians,
the disingenuousness of Samson's
advocacy comes through when he
ruthlessly attacks women, people of
color who do not share his opinion.
Below are some notable examples.
Samson is notorious for his attacks on
Patrice Zina, a black female creator who
resides in the UK. She makes videos with
nuanced commentary on various social
topics.
>> Patrice Zina, patience Zina. He doesn't
even know what's in his own lawsuit,
bro.
>> race and gender issues. During the
public controversy of Halle Bailey's
being cast as Ariel in The Little
Mermaid,
>> Dude, no way does he cite Robs Media. Oh
my god. Dude, legit Robs Media in his
footnote.
>> men, people of color who do not share
his opinion.
Below are some notable examples.
Samson is notorious for his attacks on
Patrice Zina, a black female creator who
resides in the UK. She makes videos with
nuanced commentary on various social
topics including race and gender issues.
During the public controversy of Halle
Bailey's
being cast as Ariel in The Little
Mermaid, Patience Zina agreed with the
criticism. She felt
Excuse me.
She felt Hollywood was shoehorning
people of color into Caucasian stories.
Her solution was that Hollywood should
focus on creating more content that
focuses on stories directly involving
people of color. Samson attacked
Patience Zina for her opinion and
and the destruction of Israel.
Ahmed Fouad,
described above, is a Gazan refugee.
He's a senior fellow at the Atlantic
Council where he leads the nonprofit
organization called Real Line for
Palestine. He's an advocate for the
nonviolence and of the two-state
solution to resolve the conflict between
Israel and Palestine. Samson attacks um
Al-Qa- Al-Qata- Sorry, I don't know how
to say that. Al-Qatib. Thank you. By
calling him a pro-Israel genocide
collaborator that lies for money to help
Israel genocide his people. What a
horrible [__] thing to say about a
Gazan refugee. Like, how dare you? How
dare you speak like that? You're white
dude from San Diego.
>> Okay, well, then contest the truth of
it.
Contest the truth of it. Don't just
[__] bemoan, concern troll, "How dare
you speak like that?" Contest the truth
of it. Is that true?
No, Samson probably does feel that way
about him.
>> Who never even [__] spoke about the
conflict until it was advantageous to
you on after October 7th. Let me chew my
cracker in smugness.
Let's go. Come on. Get in here.
>> He He seems very smug.
>> I'm chewing my mommy.
>> Is that what you call it, Jack?
>> [__] yeah, dude.
>> That's what I'm saying, yeah. This guy
looking very smug.
>> Let's go. Come on. Did he look more smug
to you?
>> He looks bolted. He looks legit like
This is how people look on stems.
>> [__] yeah, dude.
>> Let's go. Come on.
Okay.
The defamatory video on March 11th,
2025 defendant published a video
entitled The YouTubers
who backed the genocide. The defamatory
statement contained in the defamatory
video are identified below.
The first defamatory Whoop.
The first defamatory statement is
comprised of the thumbnail and title of
the video itself.
The thumbnail for the defamatory video
initially depicts four online content
creators, Ethan, Mutahar,
Turkey Tom, and Destiny.
The background of the thumbnail
was the devastated landscape of Gaza
Strip with a photoshopped Israeli flag.
The thumbnail depicted Ethan performing
a Nazi salute to the Israeli flag.
>> There is
no
[__]
way, dude. There is literally
no [__] way he's going to try and
make this argument, dude.
Bro.
So, guys, Ethan Klein claiming in his
lawsuit
that this is a depiction
of Ethan Klein performing a Nazi salute
to an Israeli flag. Now, I'll give you
guys I'll give you guys some charity,
okay? There may be one or two of you
[__] idiots who see this and think
Well, maybe Is he not doing that? Is
that not What's that?
Why don't we just quickly
pull up
Because think before you sleep
>> a total [__] [__] made this argument
at one point
and got totally bitched out for it.
What are you noticing here, guys? What
are you noticing here?
What are we noticing here?
Are we seeing what's actually happening
here?
It's just the content nuke.
Pose. It's the same thing. It's just
slightly bigger
over a backdrop
of Gaza.
In this one, it's an explosion. In this
one, it's rubble.
It's not a [__] Nazi salute.
This is in his lawsuit.
It's his own still.
If Noah is depicting you doing a Nazi
salute,
then you are doing a Nazi salute. That's
uh That is literally just follows. That
just follows.
This is your pose, your image that you
selected as a thumbnail image.
If you are saying that Noah using that
same image, that same pose in the same
composition in his thumbnail is
depicting you doing a Nazi salute, then
what am I supposed to read other than
that in your original video in the
thumbnail, you are depicting yourself
doing a Nazi salute?
What How else am I supposed to read
that?
How else am I supposed to read that?
This is in his [__] lawsuit, guys.
This is the first claim.
>> Sometimes after it's released, the
content creator Lunar Box described
above criticized Samson's poor research
and misrepresentation of the defamatory.
And you know what this guy did?
This arbiter of truth,
this champion of the Palestinian people,
after criticized, out of retaliation,
Samson changed the thumbnail
of the defamatory video to include an
image of Lunar Box. How [__]
insane is that? This guy
>> That's gas. That guy's hot. That guy's
hot.
Dude, that guy's hot. Dude, that guy's
hot. No, Samson. Actually, don't you
know Samson? So, and you? Uh and you?
That's awesome. No, that's hate.
>> He really thinks this is some flippant,
silly accusation to throw around, right?
>> No, I think he probably very much
substantively believes the same thing
goes for Lunar Box. I think
I don't think he's throwing it
flippantly.
I think he's probably thought about that
and he probably has seen Lonnie Box's
content and probably does genuinely
believe Lonnie Box supports genocide.
And I think that's his his right as an
American citizen protected under the
First Amendment
to say that.
>> Yo, come on. Not now. I'm kidding,
Morgan. You okay?
Just imagine that. Thinking that calling
someone backing a genocide is such a
frivolous accusation that you just add
people on a whim because they talk [__]
about you.
Seems bad faith.
>> Yeah, you want to be on the same story
bad? Here you go.
>> Um
A true and correct screenshot of the
thumbnail for the title
is depicted below.
The Nazi uh salute is a nice touch,
isn't it?
>> I'm uh lost for words, but I I genuinely
disbelieve.
Ethan.
That's your [__] thumbnail, Ethan
Ethan, it's the same as your [__]
thumbnail, Ethan. You posted the same
thing.
>> Now, by the way, for the record
>> Dude, what Wait.
>> I am not explicitly defending any of
these people as
I'm not an expert.
>> What was that face he just pulled?
>> Now
>> Look, dude, I feel like he hasn't read
this himself yet.
I feel like he hasn't actually looked at
this.
>> of the thumbnail for the title
>> the way he reacts to it.
>> is depicted below.
The Nazi uh salute is a nice touch,
isn't it?
Now, by the way, for the
>> What was that? What was that?
>> I am not explicitly defending any of
these people
>> reaction?
>> I'm not an expert.
>> It's like he's looking at it going,
"Wait.
Isn't that the same one I used in my
It's like that's literally happening.
It's like that's literally happening
live. Like he the gears are turning and
he's going, wait. Like that It just
literally looks like that's what
happened. I mean, we can't tell whether
that is what happened or whether he has
seen this already or whether he did go
through it properly before. But, that's
how it looks. That is literally the
reaction he gives there.
Just looks like he just realized that's
his thumbnail.
>> on how the body of work of any of these
people's coverage
on Israel-Palestine, right?
Speaking for my involvement in a
thumbnail called the YouTubers Packed
the Genocide. I know what I said and
what I didn't say.
These people are capable of defending
themselves and they have.
And I welcome them to,
you know.
The second defamatory statement is
Samson's false factual assertion that
Ethan spreads atrocity propaganda.
He shares that Hamas mass rape hoax. The
same hoax that was used by the Western
media, the US government, and Israeli
government to justify genocide. Good
luck with that one in court, kid.
That one might work real
>> You can just point to the UN report that
says that that there's no evidence of
mass I I believe the the UN report
literally says, does it not? There is
not We did not collect evidence of mass
systematized rape that the scope of the
investigation could not be
far off to to collect that kind of
information.
Like it I'm pretty sure that you can
just refer to
very widely accepted sources
to back up that opinion.
And it exactly, it's a it's an opinion.
It's like an assessment of contested
evidence around a
hotly debated political topic.
It's not really the sort of thing that's
going to be defamatory. Exactly. It's
like reasonable interpretation. Exactly.
>> Look cute on TikTok
and
Twitter, but good luck proving that mass
rape was a hoax.
>> Well, Ethan, fortunately, the way the US
legal system works, there's not actually
place the burden upon Noah to prove that
it was a mass that it was a mass rape
hoax. He actually doesn't have to prove
that. Now, if he could prove that, that
would be an absolute defense. But you
actually have to prove that he
maliciously lied
in saying that it was a mass rape hoax.
He does not have to prove the truth of
his claim.
That's not where the burden
lies. That's just not how it works.
>> The same hoax that was used by the
Western media, the US government, and
Israeli government to justify genocide.
Good luck with that one in court, kid.
That one might work real cute on TikTok
and
>> Not feeding the stereotypes.
>> Thank you for the journal. Thank you.
>> Twitter, but good luck proving that mass
rape was a hoax.
That it was atrocity propaganda. Good
luck with that one, bud.
Look forward to that.
The third defamatory statement is
Samson's false assertion that Ethan,
quote, Ethan spreads overt
misinformation. He just straight-up lies
about Hezbollah and the Houthis in order
to delegitimize their struggle against
Israel's genocide.
He cites baseless claims from Saudi
state propaganda outlets to attack the
Houthis.
He also cites
a documentary about the Houthis, which
he used as proof of the claim that they
brought back slavery when the
documentary wasn't even about the
Houthis, it was about the Yemeni
government before the Houthi takeover.
Fantastically
incorrect, erroneous
statement that I can't wait to see him
try to prove. Fantastic.
The fourth defamatory statement is
Samson's false assertion that he
>> that false?
I'm Maybe we'll go and look at Lion of
the Box thing.
I'm sure Lion of the Box will have a
counter arguments.
>> He He also cites a documentary about
Ansar Allah, which he uses as proof of
the claim that they brought back slavery
when the documentary wasn't even about
the Houthis, it was about the Yemeni
government before the Houthi takeover.
>> Yeah, that was a bit of an L from Ethan.
That was a big L.
Jesus [__] Christ, dude. This is not
looking good, is it?
This is looking rough.
I LEGITIMATELY
I I I seriously I expected I was going
to come here and it's like, "Oh, okay.
Now I see Samson was wrong on this one."
It's like Ethan stated confidently, he's
like, "It's a fantastically defamatory
statement that I expect him to
be raked over in court." Go Lion of the
Box to explain to me how
he [__] this one up.
Oh, yeah. That's a bit of a [__] up from
Dude, you just can't make this [__] up.
Oh my god.
>> Overall, basically
>> Okay. So, we watched that whole little
segment over that claim. It seems like
Lion of the Box thinks that's just true.
Now Samson was right about Ethan, so
how's it a false claim?
>> order to delegitimize their struggle
against
Israel's genocide.
He cites baseless claims from Saudi
state propaganda outlets to attack the
Houthis.
He also cites
a documentary about the Houthis, which
he used as proof of the claim that they
brought back slavery when the
documentary wasn't even about the
Houthis. It was about the Yemeni
government before the Houthi takeover.
Fantastically
incorrect, erroneous
statement that I can't wait to see him
try to prove.
>> Why the box seems to agree with that
completely. Why the box said that was
totally correct.
I don't
I don't understand. I don't understand.
>> Fantastic.
The fourth defamatory statement is
Samson's false assertion that he, Ethan,
in other words,
spreads long-debunked Nakba denialist
talking points.
Talking points that have been used for
decades to
to legitimize Israeli colonization
of Palestine. Once again,
can't wait to see you prove that in
court.
It's It's so nice and easy to be able to
just say [__] like that that's horrific
online.
Can't wait to see you prove it. The
fifth defamatory statement is Samson's
false assertion that Ethan cites sources
that contradict his own claims directly,
such as the UN report he claims proves
Hamas mass rapes allegations, which the
report itself denies. Can't wait for you
to prove that in court. You're wrong,
I'm right.
Works good in one of these silly little
hit videos. Let's try it on a judge.
The sixth defamatory statement is Sam's
Samson's uh false
factual assertion that he, aka Ethan,
spends 20 minutes in the video smearing
a 19-year-old survivor of the US-backed
Saudi genocide in Yemen as a terrorist
with zero credible credible evidence.
Can't wait.
Yes, he's talking about the Houthi.
The guy that Hasan introduced as a
Houthi, a guy that was photographed on
the Galaxy
boat that was pirated by the Houthis.
Photo of him a few minutes in the video
smearing a 19-year-old survivor of the
US-backed Saudi genocide in Yemen as a
terrorist with zero credible credible
evidence.
Can't wait.
Yes, he's talking about the Houthi.
The guy that Hassan introduced as a
Houthi. The guy that was photographed on
the
>> Third.
Zero credible evidence. What does Ethan
cite? Hassan said it.
Mind-blowing.
Genuinely. Genuinely.
>> The Galaxy
boat that was pirated by the Houthis.
The guy that posted
>> that was turned into a tourist
attraction that you can check a bunch of
news articles about being the case,
yeah.
>> made pictures to social media.
A guy that was photographed on the
Galaxy
boat that was pirated by the Houthis.
The guy that posted made pictures to
social media.
Saying he can't wait to spear Zionists
in the stomach,
in their [__] and out their mouth.
>> Okay.
>> Yes, that great great Houthi
young child.
>> prove he's a Houthi?
>> Innocent. Poor innocent survivor.
Can't wait.
Isn't that nice?
Samson intended for his
statements to be assertions
of fact. Excuse me.
Bun.
>> Let's go. Come on.
>> First, Samson holds himself as an expert
in this Israel-Palestine conflict.
Second, to buttress his
imprimatur of authority on the subject,
Samson will inundate his audience
with a kaleidoscope of citations, most
of which he represents or are wholly
unreliable.
This is done intentionally so Samson can
exploit his audience's low level of
knowledge on the subject matter because
he just knows that they will not
research his citations on their own.
Look, he's an expert.
In this Israel
conflict. second, to buttress his
imprimatur
of authority on the subject, Samson will
inundate his audience
with a kaleidoscope of citations, most
of which he represents or are wholly
unreliable.
This is done intentionally so Samson can
exploit his audience's low level of
knowledge on the subject matter because
he knows that they will not research his
citations on their own.
Third, Samson's tone is serious and
earnest, which is reflective in the
language he employs.
>> Yeah, I think this is just trying to cut
off various defenses that he might he
might
>> some of the reasons why Samson
Uh the first defamatory statement as
mentioned as mentioned the first
>> Dude,
there's just no [__] way. So, we're
actually getting into the actual like
laid out statements now.
So, yeah, the first one is the thumbnail
and title.
>> defamatory statement
comprised of the thumbnail.
Oopsies.
The first defamatory statement is
subject to being proven true or false.
The Merriam-Webster Dictionary defines
the verb as to back as to support by
material or moral assistance. The term
genocide is a crime
that is defined under the convention of
the prevention of punishment Article 3
as any of the following acts committed
with intent to destroy in whole or part
a national, ethnic, racial, or religious
group such as killing members of the
group, causing serious bodily or mental
harm to members of the group,
deliberately inflicting on the group
conditions of life calculated to bring
about its physical destruction in whole
or in part,
imposing measures intended to prevent
births within the group, or forcibly
transferring children of the group to
another group.
Well, Ethan,
whether Ethan provided material or moral
support to genocide acts by Israel is
subject to being proven true or false.
As demonstrated, Ethan does not and has
not supported Israel's genocide of the
Palestinian people whatsoever. It's the
contrary.
He's expressly stated the opposite and
supported numerous charities dedicated
>> Exactly. Okay, but you you haven't
debunked Noah's argument. You have
actually He needs to actually contest
Noah's argument. For
Noah's claims about Ethan
to be defamatory, they have to first be
false, right?
So,
he has to show the claims are false. It
is not enough
to disprove Noah's argument to simply
site
examples of yourself saying or doing
things in opposition
to Israel's genocide
because
Noah's claim
is specifically
about the content you produced targeting
Islam and how that has supported
genocide and how through that you have
supported genocide.
So, you need to specifically contest the
claims in that video or the arguments or
the logic in that video
to disprove that. That's how it seems to
me anyway.
It would seem absurd if you just go
No, well, one time I No, that that
doesn't fly.
>> Okay, they're doing helping
Palestinians.
>> Well, yeah, F-bombs, but that comes
after proving it's untrue, right? That
comes That's That's the next step. You
have to first prove the claim is untrue.
You know, it doesn't matter whether they
said it maliciously or not if the claim
is true.
>> As demonstrated, Ethan does not and has
not supported Israel's genocide of the
Palestinian people whatsoever.
I read that one.
Samson knew
the first defamatory statement was
>> So, that you
you haven't demonstrated that. You have
not demonstrated that at all.
>> It's false.
Because he cites the nuke.
The video
in which
has a clip of me expressly
condemning Israel's treatment of
Palestine Palestinians.
So, did you watch the video or not,
Noah? If you did, why didn't you include
that?
Salami, pause. We talked about that.
Whether Ethan
supports genocide is a provable
accusation, true or false.
And as I explicitly stated in the nuke,
I condemned Israel's treatment. Samson
engaged in similar conduct explic- ex-
ex- yeah.
Explic- ex- expressly misrepresenting
contents of the video to falsely assert
that Onas and Turkey Tom Oh, that's uh
Mutahar support Israel's genocide of the
Palestinian people as well.
The defamatory video shows two brief
clips of Mutahar's
entitled "Twitch is a disgusting evil
platform."
The defamatory video uh
says that uh Mutahar
expressly states, "I am not somebody
that is afraid to say that genocide is
wrong. I think there's an actual case
of, you know, genocide and that there's
an actual case of attack
that goes towards the Palestinian
people."
Once again, Noah's citing a video as
evidence that someone supports genocide
in a video that expressly states that
they don't support genocide.
Um Mutahar made similar statements
throughout the video.
>> Mutahar
>> Despite expressly calling Israel's
actions against Palestinian people in
Gaza genocide condemning those actions,
Samson labels him, who is Muslim, a
supporter of Israel's genocide of the
Palestinian people.
He also does the same thing to Turkey
Tom.
In the video, Turkey Tom expressly
states, "Obviously, the
Israeli-Palestinian conflict conflict is
very complicated, and I'm not trying to
say like Israel good or Palestinian good
or Palestinian bad or Israel bad."
>> This is a [__] hilarious Turkey Tom
quote.
Guys, legit, I can't wait till he reads
this out. Holy [__]
>> I
like it's not my take here. I just think
that like, you know, civilians dying is
sad and unfortunate and I don't like
that. You know, civilians aren't the
government, they're not militants, not
soldiers. They're just living somewhere
where they were born and grew up. So
obviously, you know, I'm I'm going to
feel bad for them
if they die.
>> Quite explicitly stating his sympathies
for Palestinian civilians losing their
lives, Samson labels Turkey Tom as a
supporter of Israel's genocide of the
Palestinian people.
Again, just proving like
you can criticize someone's take
without jumping to the absolutely
mind-blowingly insane, life-ruining
attack
that someone supports genocide, right?
Like you don't have to be
You don't have to do that.
The first defamatory video also portrays
Lorna Box
who's Lebanese as supporting Israel's
genocide of the Palestinian people.
After Lorna Box criticized Samson's
sloppy research, repeated
misrepresentation of sources, and overt
misinformation in the defamatory video,
Samson retaliated by including Lorna Box
in the thumbnail.
That's crazy. Samson also expressed his
desire to falsely paint Ethan
as supporting the genocide of
Palestinians for clout
and financial reasons. In fact, in the
defamatory video, Samson states, quote,
"I think many of you can probably also
help out with that because most of you
have smartphones
and cameras and TikTok. So go ahead.
Start posting about it. Spread the word.
Aside from being a morally good thing to
do, it's also becoming sustainable, you
know? It's algorithmically viable. The
Ethan Klein crash out industry complex
is booming."
That is not a very good statement to
have.
>> Why not?
>> When being accused of defamation.
>> If if you've said something defamatory,
sure.
>> Sam Seder's statement that it's
algorithmically viable
to falsely state that Ethan supports
genocide of Palestinians was correct in
fact. To date, the defamatory video is
Sam Seder's second most viewed video
video with nearly 1.5 million views. In
contrast, the video he made after that
called manufacturing consent for
genocide received only 154,000
views, 10% of what the defamatory video
received. How about that?
Flipping accusations of genocide support
pays.
In a video defend
defendant published in May 15th, Sam
Seder admitted that he included Ethan in
the thumbnail
so that the video would garner more
views.
Further, Sam Seder used the second
through
second through sixth defamatory
statements to support his factual false
factual assertion that Ethan supports a
genocide, each of which which are
discussed below.
The second and fifth defamatory
statements, both the second and fifth,
falsely assert that Ethan spread the
quote Hamas mass rape hoax or quote
Hamas mass rape allegations.
To support these assertions, Sam Seder
falsely asserts that Ethan
misrepresented the contents
of the March 4th report from the United
Nations Office of Special Representative
of the Secretary-General on Sexual
Violence in Conflict entitled mission
report.
The official visit
>> I think Ethan did misrepresent this.
>> visit of the office of the
R
SRSG to Israel and the occupied
Westbank.
Uh Westbank 29 January to 14th February.
Paragraph 84 through 86 of the UN report
refute
Samson's false assertions.
That this statement he made accident
absolutely blew my mind cuz I'm like
wow, he just can straight up lie about
what it says
in a video to 1.5 million people and
nobody actually cares about what it
actually said. I read that report.
I did the research. I included it in my
video.
Paragraph 84 of the UN report states the
following, quote, overall based on the
totality of information gathered from
multiple and independent sources at the
different locations, there are
reasonable grounds to believe
>> Yeah, dude, literally this is the quote.
This is the quote.
Like
that it's always fought over.
And it is not saying
there was mass rape.
As far as
you know,
I can interpret, as far as I've ever
looked into.
It is saying
there is reason to believe
multiple
rapes occurred.
That's what it's saying. Now, mass rape
mass systematized rape
this is like a separate claim.
>> believe that conflict-related sexual
violence occurred at several locations
across the Gaza periphery, including in
the form of rape, gang rape, during the
October 7th attacks. Credible
circumstantial information
which may be indicative of some form of
sexual violence, including genital
mutilation, sexual torture, or cruel,
inhumane, and degrading
>> Yeah, so that there's also no video
evidence of sexual assault as far as I'm
aware Xariot is saying. Um it's it's
what they call circumstantial evidence,
like
the the state of bodies and stuff like
that.
And um
like the types of wounds incurred
and the positioning when when they were
found, I think
is is a sort of thing they're looking
at. Now, they couldn't collect forensic
evidence, either.
Uh and I know Luna Box gets really anal
about the reason why.
It's like
something there's like
they have to bury the bodies within like
48 hours or something for some religious
[__]
Um
there's something else to it, though.
There's some other part to it that I'm
forgetting.
Some other argument Luna Box leans on.
I feel like I spoke to him about it, but
I can't remember.
>> And treatment was also gathered.
Noah
said that I faked that.
Which is not just cruel and
defamatory to me,
but also
such a disgusting
such a disgusting attack on the victims
of of a terrorist
attack, of a violent terrorist sexual
attack.
Again,
there's no reason to support Hamas. He
and people like him think it's some kind
of moral imperative to support Hamas.
And when you do that, this is what
happens.
You end up attacking victims of sexual
assault
and lying
>> How does he come not only have a family
and tens of millions of dollars of net
worth and a large house, but access to
the best doctors in the world, and you
think this is an acceptable use of your
time?
>> Thank you for the donation.
>> I'm logging some soy boy. Sad.
>> Thank you. Thank you.
>> lying about them
in service of this completely
pointless lie.
Paragraph 85 of the UN reports also
states with regard to the hostages, the
mission team found clear and convincing
information that some hostages taken to
the have been subject to various forms
of conflict-related violence and has
reasonable grounds to believe that such
violence is ongoing.
Paragraph 86 of the UN report states the
mission team was unable to establish the
prevalence of sexual violence and
concludes the overall magnitude, scope,
and specific attribution of these
violations would require a fully-fledged
investigation. Comprehensive
investigation would enable the
information
base to be expanded in locations which
the mission team was not able to visit
and to build the required trust with
supervisors and victims of
conflict-related sexual violence who may
be reluctant to come forward at this
point.
The aforementioned paragraph make it
clear
>> No.
That there were numerous instances of
sexual violence. No.
No, it says there is some circumstantial
evidence supporting the idea.
It's not It does not state as fact that
it happened. That's not true.
>> That there were numerous instances of
sexual violence perpetrated by Hamas
against Israel
Israelis at several locations on October
7th. This is not in dispute. Rather,
further investigation was necessary to
determine the overall magnitude, scope,
and specific attributions of these
numerous acts of sexual violence.
Samson expressly misrepresented the
contents of the UN report to knowingly
and intentionally paint Ethan as lying
about Hamas engaging in numerous acts of
sexual violence on October 7th,
ironically doing the same thing he's
accusing me of.
Samson knew he misrepresented the UN
reports because of his repeated
lionization of Hamas as  heroic
resistance.
To acknowledge their sexual violence
would contradict his narrative and
demonstrate he supports sexual assault.
Indeed, immediately after the second
defamatory statement, Samson cites
materials he claims support his
assertion that that the Hamas mass rape
hoax was used by the Western media, the
US government, and the Israeli
government to
to justify genocide. The material he
cites, however, only discusses
conflict-related sexual violence in
general
and not just on October 7th.
And it does not discuss Israel's action
in Gaza whatsoever.
Bite of Orange.
>> Oh, well, if they don't literally say,
"And that's why it's okay to kill all
the Gazans," then they can't possibly be
using it to support that kind of
[__] idiot. Like, what are we even
trying to
Who is falling for this?
>> The third defamatory statement falsely
asserts that Ethan spread, quote, "overt
misinformation and straight-up lies
about Hezbollah
and the Houthis." In the nuke, Ethan
pointed out the following facts about
Hezbollah.
One,
it engaged in terrorism resulting in the
death of thousands of civilians.
Two, it orchestrated the assassination
of Lebanese Prime Minister
Rafic al-Hariri. It hijacked airplanes.
It fired 15,000 rockets into civilian
areas. It intervened in the civilian in
the Syrian Civil War
to aid
the dictator Bashar al-Assad, which
resulted in the deaths of 100,000
civilians.
Its former leader, Hassan Nasrallah,
rest in piss, made numerous anti-Semitic
and genocidal statements against Jews.
And seven, it initiated the most recent
round of fighting on October 8th, not
Israel, which resulted in hundreds of
Israelis killed and over 200,000
displaced.
Despite asserting that Ethan spread
overt misinformation and straight-up
lies about Hezbollah, Samson failed to
identify, let alone prove,
any statements Ethan made in the nuke
about Hezbollah that was false. Samson
failed to do so because he knew that
Ethan's statements were true.
In the nuke, Ethan points out the
following facts about the Houthis.
They recruit They recruit child
soldiers. They shell civilians. They
block aid to civilians. They ruin
agricultural land with mines. They
oppress women and members of the LGBT Q
community. They torture and kill women.
They They perform Nazi salutes. Their
flag states death to Israel and curse
upon the Jews.
After the hip Galaxy leader
>> So, it was just all grand in the middle
of a lawsuit, just like the last one.
Awesome to see.
>> in international waters, not Yemeni
waters.
And the ship was not destined or even
traveling to or from Israel.
>> Okay, leaving out the fact that I
believe the owner was Israeli, if I
remember correctly. It was like a It was
like half-owned by an Israeli, I
believe.
But, hey.
>> They took the crew of the Galaxy Leader,
who were not Israeli, hostages.
Despite asserting that Ethan was
spreading overt misinformation and
straight-up lies about the Houthis, Sam
Seder fails to address, let alone
refute, any of the aforementioned
statements Ethan made about the Houthis.
Sam Seder failed to do so because he
knew Ethan's statements were true, and
he had no evidence to contradict those
statements because none exist. And guess
what? Now's your opportunity, Noah.
Can't wait to see what you got.
Instead, Sam Seder solely focused on
Ethan's assertion that the Houthis
engage in slavery. Sam Seder does not
provide evidence refuting Ethan's
assertion. Rather, Sam Seder tries to
attack the two sources two sources cited
in the nuke
to support the assertion that Houthis
engage in slavery. One, an article
entitled
Exclusive: Houthis Restore Slavery to
Yemen.
That's the title of the article. And a
documentary by Al Jazeera World entitled
Slavery in Yemen.
>> Okay, well,
is that Yeah, that's the Saudi state
media one.
That Noah said was Saudi state media.
I I just like cite something else, man.
Like
Is it really that hard? Is it really
that hard?
It's just that it's just the Saudi state
media one.
>> Sam Seder makes the assertion
that the Al Sharq Al Al Awsat article
contains baseless claims from Saudi
state outlets without any supporting
evidence. Samson's conclusions and
assertions are false.
>> So,
they they cite receiving information
from these places.
Noah's saying it's baseless cuz they
don't present evidence that this is
Saudi state media, which it is. It's
owned by So, it's it's owned by uh Saudi
Research and Media Group, SRMG,
which is a Saudi state-backed media
company.
>> The Al-Sharq Al-Awsat article cited
receiving information from one, close
sources close to the Houthis, two,
several local reports, three, Yemeni
activists, four, lawyers in Yemen, five,
a civilian who works for a pro-Houthi
tribal leader. Further, the United
States State Department cited the the
Al-Sharq Al-Awsat article
in 2022 country reports on human rights
practices, Yemen, for the the
proposition that quote
>> US State Department said it.
>> The newspaper
Al-Sharq Al-Awsat reported in the 2019
that prominent Houthis held more than
1,800 civilians citizens as slaves and
servants who worked in their residence
and places of work. Imagine
defending slavers
to own the libs.
>> Yeah, I've like, you know, I've always
heard the Houthis do slavery. I you
know,
I assume it to be true. I haven't looked
into it massively.
But, Ethan's arguments here against Noah
[__] suck. They absolutely suck.
>> Would you even take that position? Good
luck, though. Samson intentionally
misrepresented the context of the
article because he knew it it ran
counter to his native narrative of the
Houthis being quote heroic resistance
and exploited the fact that he knew his
audience would not read the article.
Samson makes the assert the assertion
that Ethan represented the Al Jazeera
documentary because it was released
before the Houthi takeover of Yemen.
This is false. The Al Jazeera
documentary was
released
September 10th, 2014. The Houthis
already controlled parts of Yemen as
early as March 2011
with the battle of Sa'dah.
Additionally, the battle of
Sana'a, which cemented Houthi control
over northern Yemen, began prior to the
release of the Al
>> Yeah, but okay, but obviously the
documentary wasn't made like like it's
been made over a period of time, right?
Dude, even Lone Wolf is against him on
this stupid [__] claim.
So so Ethan is claiming
this documentary he showed is about
well, it was supposed to be about the
Houthis. It was supposed to support
his claims about the Houthis.
But it was actually talking about Yemen
while it was controlled by the previous
Yemeni government.
>> victims
The Ethiopian refugees who have spoken
to human rights organizations, including
uh Human Rights Watch, are they uh Saudi
propagandists as well?
>> attack the Houthis. He also cites a
documentary about Ansar Allah, which he
uses as proof of the claim that they
brought back slavery when the
documentary wasn't even about the
Houthis. It was about the Yemeni
government before the Houthi takeover.
>> Yeah, that was a big L from Ethan. That
was a big L.
>> The fact is is that the Yemeni
government and
>> So even Lone Wolf is totally against
Ethan on this.
And and sees that this is a documentary
not about
the Houthis, but about Yemen
specifically under the previous Yemeni
government before the Houthis took over.
Now, they're saying here
it was released. When is
So
they're talking about the 2014 Battle of
Sana'a.
So
what
Dude.
Huh?
Am I going crazy?
The Wikipedia says the Battle of Sana'a
started on September 16th.
That's what Wikipedia says, okay?
This was released September 10th.
And yet in the lawsuit they claim the
Battle of Sa'dah started before the
release of the documentary.
So,
who's wrong here? Wikipedia or Ethan's
lawyers or
Mhm.
Fighting began on the 9th of September.
Okay. So, the first bit of fighting, so
the first fighting that eventually
turned into the Battle of Sa'dah started
on the 9th of September.
So, one day
before this documentary was released,
the first bit of fighting that
eventually materialized into the battle
that led to the Houthis taking more
control over Yemen.
One day before the documentary, the
first bit of fighting started. And Ethan
is using that to say, "Oh, actually no,
it is about the Houthis. It is about the
Houthis."
No, dude. The documentary was already
[__] made by that point, obviously.
>> Al Jazeera documentary. Moreover, the Al
Jazeera documentary focus on Yemen's
overall slate culture of slavery, not
merely the deposed government. Indeed,
the Houthis engage in human trafficking
is well documented.
2023 an independent Yemeni human rights
organization, Watana, found that the
Houthis forcibly recruit African
migrants and deployed them to the front
lines of conflict zones then refused to
pay them. Further, independent published
article reporting on the Houthis
engaging in sex trafficking supported by
statements from Yemeni victims, lawyers,
and human rights activists. Noah Sams
says that now
I will support the slavers and the sex
traffickers to own the libs.
Let's own the libs, brother.
Samson intentionally misrepresented the
timeline because he knew that the
Houthis engage in slavery contradicted
his assertion that they were heroic
resistance. And he knew his audience
would not take the time to watch the Al
Jazeera documentary on their own.
We're coming to the end. The fourth
defamatory statement falsely asserts
that Ethan denied the Nakba to lead to
legitimize Israeli's colonization.
But nowhere does Noah Samson identify
what Ethan said that denied the Nakba,
how those points were debunked, and how
those talking points legitimized Israeli
colonization. Instead, Samson showed a
screenshot from a video by the great
reputable BadEmpanada
entitled Nakba Denier Explosion Liar
Content Nuke Destroyed Number Six by the
great scholar
BadEmpanada.
>> BadEmpanada
>> I like to call him, BadEmpanada.
>> With the text just quoted, this is Sam's
This is Noah's source on this. He just
said, quote, on screen, "Debunked by
BadEmpanada." Boom. Checkmate. Got him.
BadEmpanada has a notorious reputation
for his full-throated support of
violence and terrorism against Israel
and Israelis, particularly on October
7th. He spread intentional falsehoods
and misinformation about his enemies,
including harassing and doxing them. At
the top of BadEmpanada's hit list are
Ethan and Neela. Samson is well aware of
BadEmpanada's extreme antagonism towards
Ethan, Israel, and Israelis. Due to
Samson's close relationship with him, it
is highly likely that BadEmpanada played
a substantial role in the creation of
the defamatory video.
Like BadEmpanada's other videos,
BadEmpanada's video cited by Samson is
replete with misinformation. In the
BadEmpanada video, BadEmpanada asserts
that Ethan Klein attempts to justify the
Israeli settler-colonial state by
glossing over the Nakba. BadEmpanada's
video not only is false, but BadEmpanada
also fails to show any clip of Ethan
doing so.
Rather, BadEmpanada shows Ethan
discussing one, that Jews would not
feel safe
Excuse me.
as an ethnic minority.
>> sure the judge is going to find this
very compelling.
He cited BadEmpanada. Say no more,
Ethan. Say no more.
>> refugees
from Europe and
Arab countries and following the 1948
war, there were more Jews displaced than
Palestinians during the Nakba and
forward that there are hardly any Jews
left in Arab countries. None of these
statements deny the Nakba or downplay
it, but it's a fact that approximately
900,000 Jews migrated flood or expelled
from Muslim majority countries
throughout Africa and Asia
primarily as a consequence of the
establishment of the state of Israel.
And the Nakba turned 700,000
Palestinians into refugees, which was
mainly
is mainly caused by Israeli arms.
Even worse, the Bad Empanada video
advances an historical narrative about
the exodus of Jews from Morocco,
Algeria, and Iraq. As to Morocco, Bad
Empanada grossly misrepresents the
historical record by claiming Jews the
Jewish agency struck an agreement with
the French government to force Moroccan
Jews to migrate. Bad Empanada video
explains below is false. This is just
This is just um
provable
uh falsehoods
and Bad Empanada's research, surprise,
surprise.
Which I can skip. You can read that with
for your own pleasure.
More about Bad Bad Bad Empanada being a
terrible actor, a liar.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
>> Bad which
which was mainly mainly caused by
Israeli arms.
Let's not skip this.
Even worse, the Bad Empanada video
advances an historical narrative about
the exodus of Jews from Morocco,
Algeria, and Iraq. As to Morocco, Bad
Empanada grossly misrepresents the
historical record by claiming Jews the
Jewish agency struck an agreement with
the French government to force Moroccan
Jews to migrate.
>> Is this Is he really just running about
Bad Empanada's removal of Jews? Okay.
>> provable
uh falsehoods
and Bad Empanada's research, surprise,
surprise.
Which I can skip. You can read that with
for your own pleasure.
More about Bad Bad Bad Empanada being a
terrible actor, a liar.
Who Noah of course leans on as a
credible source.
And then here he is, he gets Jewish
Iraqi history wrong.
And this is all
necessary to showing
what a bad actor Ben Shapiro is and how
laughable
that Noah put something on screen like
Ethan denying Nakba or whatever he
wrote.
And then just put in quote, Ben Shapiro
proved this.
Really?
Blah blah
Ben Shapiro, yada yada.
Samson made the fourth defamatory
statement with knowledge of falsity or
reckless disregard for the truth because
among other things he knew that Ben
Shapiro
like Samson himself was an unreliable
source of information with an extreme
bias against Israel, Ethan, Israel and
Israelis.
Ben Shapiro video did not identify a
single statement that Ethan said it that
supports his assertion that Nakba of
Nakba denial and Samson was more
concerned with prompt
promul- promulgating
promulg- gating his false narrative
about denying atrocities made
against Arab Jews to advance his
genocidal rhetoric. The sixth defamatory
statement search that Ethan labeled
the sweet Houthi
>> Wait, so let's run that back.
>> search that supports his assertion that
Nakba of information with an extreme Ben
Shapiro
Samson made the fourth defamatory
statement with knowledge of falsity or
reckless disregard for the truth because
among other things he knew that Ben
Shapiro like Samson himself was an
unreliable source of information with an
extreme bias against Israel, Ethan,
Israel and Israelis.
Ben Shapiro video did not identify a
single statement that Ethan said it that
supports his assertion that Nakba of
Nakba
>> Okay, so
you can absolutely is I've seen you easy
as [__] argument. that Ethan is a Nakba
denialist
Nakba denier.
Right?
If you would call a Holocaust if a
Holocaust denier someone that says, "Uh
maybe it wasn't 6 million."
Ethan is a Nakba denier.
Ethan
under counted, I believe, and drew a
false equivalence to another
to to the exodus of Jews from Arab
countries.
So, it is an easy as [__] argument to
call this guy a Nakba denier.
>> for denial. And Samson was more
concerned with prompt
promul- promulgating
promulg- gating his false narrative
about denying atrocities made
against Arab Jews to advance his
genocidal rhetoric. The sixth defamatory
statement asserts that Ethan labeled
the sweet Houthi
>> Is this is it actually that that's
revisionism not denial? I think it
happened it just wasn't that bad.
>> The sweet sweet Luthy the Hoof Luthy the
Houthi
Rashid threatened to sue me now 20
times.
And he has a GoFundMe he's doing great.
That I said he's a terrorist with zero
credible evidence.
This one's going to be rough to prove,
buddy.
The nuke shows various social media
posts of Al
>> Again, no it actually doesn't have to
prove any of these claims. Like you have
to prove that false and the
um
they were made
uh with malice or reckless disregard for
the truth.
>> Haddad admitting to being a Houthi
terrorist
expressing support for the Houthis and
echoing their genocidal rhetoric. The
nuke shows also clips of Al Haddad
discussing visiting the galaxy leader,
the ship hijacked by the Houthis, and
interacting with hostages taken by the
crew.
Despite claiming to have never seen the
nuke, Samson failed to disclose, let
alone explain why the social media posts
and interviews cited by Ethan and The
Nuke failed to support Ethan's claim
that Al-Haddad was a member of the
Houthis. Samson failed to do so because
he knew he couldn't fail school. Look at
their genocidal rhetoric. The Nuke shows
also clips of Al-Haddad discussing
visiting the Galaxy Leader, the ship
hijacked by the Houthis, and interacting
with hostages taken by the crew.
Despite claiming to have never seen The
Nuke, Samson failed to disclose, let
alone explain why the social media posts
and interviews cited by Ethan and The
Nuke failed to support Ethan's claim
that Al-Haddad was a member of the
Houthis. Samson failed to do so because
he knew
>> Yep.
But they don't support the claim.
What What's the evidence?
The idea that he was on the Galaxy
Leader, the Galaxy Leader was turned
into a tourist attraction.
The idea that Hassan said he was a
Houthi, that's not credible whatsoever.
Who gives a [__] what Hassan said?
The idea that he was doing cat with the
prisoners,
that's not uh proven.
And it's believed it's referring to a
misattributed TikTok that wasn't
actually showing that,
but
wasn't him doing it anyway. He was
referring to other people doing it.
And he called himself a soldier in an
Instagram post,
which again does not prove the claim.
>> So he could not do so.
We sent him a demand for retraction at
an abundance of caution. The demand
The direction The re-
retraction demand was sent to his email.
Physical copy was sent to
Well, yada yada.
Samson refused to comply with the
retraction. Furthermore, he began to
flaunt his refusal
and continued to attack Ethan along with
Ethan Ethan Filla.
And And as detailed below, May 15th,
Samson released a video stating he would
not comply with the retraction, even
though the deadline to comply had long
passed. He called it a joke.
Sam so we're going to make a number of
videos and social media posts that
double down on his claims against Ethan,
attack Ela as a war criminal, and attack
their Arab employee as a race traitor.
How nice of him to say white.
A white [__] dude from
>> Tell me you know what?
>> San Diego who never spoke about the
conflict before October 7th has the
balls to call a
a Lebanese dude a race traitor. What a
[__]
piece of [__]
Uh December uh 14th Samson was
interviewed where he continued to flaunt
Ethan into suing him.
So anyway, we got the defamation, we got
the
the yada yada
and the blah blah blah.
This is restating the defamatory causes,
blah blah blah, yada yada,
Bob's your uncle as they say. Why's he
keep doing that?
Blah blah blah, yada yada, Bob's your
uncle, demand for trial jury, prayer for
relief, and there it is.
>> No, not yada yada yada.
>> So anyway, we got the def
mation, we
got the
the yada yada
and the blah blah blah.
>> watching. We know you're watching.
Where's the stream, buddy?
>> This is restating the defamatory com
>> They're claiming it's per se. They're
claiming they're not claiming damages, I
guess.
>> causes,
blah blah blah, yada yada,
Bob's your
uncle as they say. Why's he
>> Yeah, these are just it's just more of
the same, basically.
Wow, that was [__] atrocious. What an
idiot.